c'est une vraie surprise pour Mathieu
Delormeau
ah génial Mathieu j'ai une énorme
surprise pour toi tu as trouvé un
mannequin tu peux rester là pour
l'instant bon
tu l'as compris derrière ce rideau il y
a quelqu'un pour toi il assume vrai
surprise et quelqu'un qui a quelque
chose à te dire Mathieu ok tout ce que
je peux dire c'est que cette personne ne
parle pas français
Mathieu tu vas voir un indice en vidéo
pour commencer pour voir qui est cette
personne qui est venue expressément te
voir regarde
Matthieu on dit souvent qu'une star est
inaccessible pour le commun des mortels
mais ce qu'une star est accessible pour
une autre star
on remercie Malek délégué
alors
quelques idées
et vraiment là je ne rigole pas du tout
c'est pas une vanne c'est une star
internationale qui est venue pour vous
ce soir j'ai voulu vous faire une
surprise vraiment je ne charrie pas du
tout et qui a un message pour vous qui
va vous faire extrêmement plaisir
prise est-ce que vous êtes connu dans le
monde entier je peux are you
World yes
est-ce que Mathieu Delormeau vous
connaît surprise
[Musique]
il dit qu'il l'a déjà rencontré je pense
à deux personnes déjà
mais il y a deux stars internationales
que je connaisse bien et qui me
connaissent bien pour le coup avec qui
on a mis Elton John Enrique Iglesias
mais comme Elton John n'est pas
disponible en même temps Aymeric et son
fils qui m'adorent aussi non bah
regardez avec cette question
est-ce que vous avez plus de 60 ans
une star internationale qui est venue
vous voir Mathieu ce soir je vous jure
que c'est vrai c'est une surprise pour
vous et je vous promets que c'est vrai
une petite surprise pour vous un message
pour vous et Mathieu ce soir
on te fait plaisir
vous voulez vraiment faire plaisir à
notre ami Mathieu
mon ami m'a tué
c'est une star internationale on l'a vu
elle parle anglais star es-tu toujours
là
oui je suis là c'est bon
[Rires]
physiquement comment vous pouvez vous
décrire cher star
de Pierre-Emmanuel donc programmateur il
y a 10 jours qui m'a dit peux-tu me
donner le numéro de téléphone de
l'assistant d'Elton John je dirais
manuel j'adore H2O j'adore le public
dans laquelle c'est impossible c'est
vraiment mon ami je pourrais pas faire
ça je vais te donner un indice
[Rires]
Mathieu
cette personne parle anglais bah oui
vous l'aimez beaucoup elle est
excentrique à la plus de 60 ans
vous pensez à qui je pense
qui c'est le genre à dire oui pour moi
c'est qui
est-ce que vous voulez qu'on ouvre le
rideau
tu crois pas que tu crois pas que je le
connais
est-ce que vous voulez qu'on ouvre le
rideau est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
ouvre le rideau
c'est une
immense star
c'est pour moi peut-être une des trois
plus grandes stars mondiales 80 de
disques de platine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
il va t'aimer si je t'aime transition
c'est beau
c'est énorme parce que franchement moi
j'en ai des frissons je vous jure que
c'est vrai
Mathieu mon ami énormément de temps à le
faire venir je te donne vraiment ça a
été une bataille de tous les instants on
a réussi
à ce qu'il soit là ce soir juste il est
où le gars qui prenait les photos de
tout à l'heure la pub là c'est
maintenant qui doit être là
que l'invité de ce soir cette star
internationale vient ne vient que pour
Mathieu
c'est fort
cette star internationale elle vient
pour toi elle a un message à te faire
passer j'espère que ça te fera plaisir
j'espère ça qu'on a payé pour la voir
l'hébergement
le transport
des gens qui font un effort de traverser
la Manche pour toi la branche
à qui tu penses vraiment mais
je pensais à Enrique j'ai vu il y a pas
très longtemps mais plus de 60 ans
on s'est parlé cet été donc je pense à
Elton John Elton
c'est une vraie star internationale
qu'on a réussi à faire venir pour toi ce
soir regarder la musique en bande de
connards
[Rires]
c'est une vraie star internationale
qu'on a réussi à faire venir pour toi ce
soir je vais demander de reculer un
petit peu
de reculer qu'il recule complètement
complètement
[Applaudissements]
cette star Mathieu elle va venir te voir
parce qu'elle a un message à te faire
passer
[Musique]
as en cause toute
la stérilisation avec des amis que je
connais et tout ça Mathieu Mathieu
il est là ce soir pour toi c'est la plus
grande star internationale de tous les
temps pour une réussite incroyable
Mathieu demande d'accueillir
ton invité de ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Mickey Mouse et là encore Mathieu et
Mickey Mickey je crois que tu as un
message pour Mathieu ce soir
[Rires]
si je suis venu ce soir
c'est pour une bonne nouvelle
on a vu qu'ils étaient vous suivez pas
ce qui se passe c'est pour une très
bonne nouvelle une très bonne nouvelle
je connais beaucoup de dirigeants chez
Canal+
et on est d'accord tous pour faire le
bilan qui est suivant ta rentrée
exceptionnelle en tant qu'animateur
et si je suis à côté de Cyril sur ce
plateau
c'est pour t'annoncer quelque chose de
très bien c'est qu'on trouve que tu es
pas assez mis en valeur
et on a décidé avec l'ensemble de la
direction et Cyril
notamment c'est solennellement que les
docks Disney sur C8 c'est fini
[Applaudissements]
c'est notre directeur des programmes des
antennes de tout Vincent Pujols
j'ai failli faire une Jean-Michel maire
pour ceux qui savent ah oui
merci
pour le doc non
est-ce que vraiment vous avez essayé de
gens à Dalton
[Musique]
c'est vraiment